I'm done
where was he going 2022 marked another
wild year in the 90-day Universe clearly
Ximena had Mike doing the most
she also had him dressing like Vin
Diesel y'all remember that and oh can't
forget this year we saw Gino's head for
the first time
and we laughed so hard at the word
Sparkles who would have thought we'll go
upstairs but I don't want this dude up
there okay Sparkles no problem I'm gonna
knock him out if you bring him up there
on a more heartfelt note though we even
shed tears with some of our 90-day cast
I'm just worried about my family friends
everywhere about my country about my
people about everybody because every
single person it's my person not only my
friends but not only my family obviously
sad tears but also happy ones can get my
height together
I mean that one was something else so in
the spirit of 90 day replay we're gonna
take a look back at the 10 biggest
moments that happened on 90 Day Fiance
this year including some of your best
reactions I can't wait
I can't wait let's get into it
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia happy
holidays oh boy we had a time this year
well we had a time last night
are you that friend who speaks in Tick
Tock language
I'm not but my friends are rubbing off
on me clearly for those of you who don't
get it basically what I'm saying is that
so much went down in 2022 I thought this
year went by fast but I started putting
together this countdown and I was like
wow we were in Geno in Jasmine land this
year that just seemed so long ago but
all right let's not waste any more time
let's get into the countdown coming in
at number 10 is mahogany inviting Ben to
her home but giving him a tour of an
apartment that was clearly not hers
do you want to tour for my home yeah I'd
love to see it at this time Ben was 52
and mahogany was 22. although she
initially told Ben she was 24 but that
was a lie
anyway considering their age difference
and then giving off creepy Vibes I
understood why mahogany didn't want to
tell Ben where she lived but I just
couldn't get over this unnecessary act
that she put on talk about staying
committed to character it was
mind-blowing this is my bathroom
beautiful okay this is
then there was this random surfboard
that she could not explain
I love that surfboard who serves here
who serves that's nice it's not my
decoration no yes oh okay
here's what Ben had to say about it when
we chatted I just you know wonder why
she didn't say I don't want to give you
my home address then let's meet here she
was living there you know she was
actually living there and she lived
there for a couple months apparently
because her bedroom was empty I was like
is this a 24 year old woman's bedroom
yeah so I'm sure that most of her stuff
was at her parents house Ben wanted to
believe mahogany at all cost and I hate
to call the girl a liar but
okay we don't have to call her a liar
let's just say she lied
a few times BB All-Star 30 says quote
Ben gives off Lifetime movies stalker
energy
no comment but he did say he used to act
so maybe he should take up that craft
again and bring mahogany along with him
all right moving on to number nine on
the countdown
text me though I don't understand we
will have sex
y'all remember Kim's meltdown because
Usman wouldn't sleep with her oh this
was rough she received so much backlash
from what happened that night
just admit you don't want me if you if
you admit that I'm fine
no I didn't say that
if I don't want to I will not invite you
right
I'm gonna get some more champagne
because I can't live like that with that
Malin oscarson says quote I don't
understand how anyone would want to have
sex with someone who doesn't want to
have sex with them knowing they are not
into it it would be horrible I agree
Malin I also know that that rejection
wound that some of us have oof will have
us trying to avoid the feeling of
rejection at all cost unfortunately in
Kim's case even if that means not
accepting no I embarrassed myself I
embarrassed Usman I embarrassed my son
you know and the crazy thing was
I was drinking a lot and I'm not using
alcohol excuse but I had like three
bottles of champagne three bottles of
champagne I did not catch that because I
was nervous I was really nervous about
like you know this young guy in here I
am 50 years old I'm like hey you know I
was nervous but the way I acted I was
mortified I was mortified and like I
will never live that down I don't think
yeah that wasn't cool it was a hard
lesson Kim had to learn but a year later
she became using his whole fiancee he
put a ring on it oh goodness if you had
told Ken in this moment that a year
later she would be engaged to Usman what
do you think she would have done
best case scenario she would have
chilled out relax girl all right on to a
more somber Note coming in at number
eight yara's reaction to the war in her
home country of Ukraine my family is
located in Western in Western Ukraine
right now and my friends are located in
Kiev
so July for my uh French right now it's
uh in the day in the bathtub
and at night they are under the ground
the reason why I wanted to make sure
that this was included in the countdown
is because there are some who are
unaware that there is still a full-blown
war going on in Ukraine with this 24 7
News cycling things moving so fast on
social media it can be easy to become
numb to the suffering of others in this
world so let's take a moment right here
right now to send love energetically
mentally however you want to do it to
those who are affected by this war
whether you think so or not every bit of
positive energy counts especially when
we do it together and I know for some of
you even if you're not in the middle of
a war zone it might feel as if things
are crashing down around you so I'm
taking the time to send you my love as
well the truth is the holidays aren't a
season of cheer for everyone and I
always try to keep that in mind I wish I
could say that one thing that could make
you feel better but I don't have that
magic pill all I will say though is just
remember you're never alone and if you
don't give up better days will come you
may spend the rest of your life walking
with a limp for what you've been through
and and the loss that you have but
you can do it yes you can
alright moving on to number seven are we
going ballistic on binium's female MMA
training partner
can you just watch Avi for a minute it's
about to go down
reset
so you didn't think to tell me that you
would be training with a girl hey this
is your friend what's wrong
what's your name just talk to me no I'm
talking to her what's your name
so you have full makeup I'm usually when
you get out of my way Miss H said quote
I already didn't have to run up on home
girl like that especially when she's
training to be an MMA fighter right
but jealousy can have the same effect as
that Liquid Courage the moment you start
feeling that heat in your chest oof you
are on go if you have a boyfriend right
you do you tell him the people that you
train with
um I don't have a boyfriend but let me
tell you something this game you gotta
go with who you gotta go right but yeah
you still wear fake eyelashes to the gym
what if she has lash extensions Ari you
can't just pull those off
she really came for her looking cute he
Cooley said quote Ari should have kept
that same energy with binium sisters
I am with you on that especially after
his sister wished through that red wine
in Ari's face my only hesitation though
is I don't think beniam sisters would
have had the same restraint as MMA
fighter Melissa it could have gone real
bad yeah
coming in at number six Mike running off
into the streets of Columbia after
Ximena broke up with him
Dakota
you know what I'm done
I don't know what I did wrong everything
she said on the first trip I tried to
fix myself
what are you fixing
my mind's going crazy
he's a runner he's a track star he's
gonna run away when it gets I still
don't know where Mike thought he was
going late at night with that bright
yellow shirt on in a foreign country
Mary Jane said quote props to the
cameraman running after Mike like they
do on Mari
if I was the cameraman I would have been
mad Mike running toward an alley while
it's dark puts him in a dangerous
position with all of that expensive
equipment Nicholas Garrick said Mike's
run at the end was really giving quote
Paul sprinting into the Bush's energy I
hope she understands I can't be with her
it's just not going to work
again where are you going Carini was so
confused that's a throwback thanks for
that one Nicholas
all right number five below pranking
shaida by taking her to his run-down
childhood home and acting as if that's
where they're going to live
a home from the 1900s lesbian antique
it's called historic
baby
oh
right
hey
now Bilal caught this a prank but it was
also a test to see if shaida just wants
him for his money and it was the start
of him becoming one of the most hated
cast members in the 90-day Universe
unfortunately people they may be going
through some things in their own
personal life so they'll project you
know what's going on in their life or
relationships or whatever onto you but
forget the flag that Bilal received I
received a lot of flack from my opinion
because at the time I thought shaida was
focusing too much on the material
matters and it seemed as if the love
they shared just went out the window you
want something to eat yeah something
that's from a clean Bowl yeah
well I can order something
I know you don't want to eat you have
enough money for that I will say that
some of your opinions and getting more
of a gist of shaida's Personality my
perspective on this moment in particular
changed MX trxd said in part quote
someone who flexes online with flashy
designer luggage and watches but doesn't
take care of his home is a huge red flag
for misplaced priorities even if you
don't care about money that points to
someone irresponsible with their
finances
very true very true hey one thing I've
learned is that I don't always have to
be right okay you got to be flexible in
the mind and it's okay for your opinion
to change or evolve and in this case
mine definitely did
coming in at number four Angela
physically attacking Michael after she
popped up on him unannounced in Nigeria
what is the meaning of this
you [ __ ]
Nicholas said quote Angela is out of her
mind she put her hands on Michael first
she's lucky Michael was raised to
respect his elders
Nicholas again thank you for bringing
some levity to what otherwise was a very
disturbing incident B kajaiji hopefully
I pronounced your name right said quote
Michael needs an honorary Green Card
he's been through more than enough with
Angela now let's pretend that this
honorary green card is a real thing
if Michael was awarded do you think he
would still be with Angela
my face it says it all let me know what
you think in the comments
all right moving on to number three on
the countdown one of my favorite moments
this season John and jabri's Sparkle
argument
Sparkle
do you think your brother is whipped
yeah yeah
100
yep without a doubt I love you though
love you but you definitely wept you
went you happy you don't have a happy
family
you won't okay Speckles okay no ass will
never you were joking I was having a
conversation with him but then you
opened your mouth and then I have to
respond I am I apologize you need to
stop third Wheeling bro third Wheeling
yeah you all in a business like this
your brother how's your family doing on
your phone it's not your brothers
Ross M said quote John is seriously the
only person in the room being himself
and not fronting like he's something
he's not that says everything that's
true John never said he was perfect he
comes as he is whether you like it or
not
I guess we gotta get you back upstairs I
don't I don't want to go upstairs with
you
no I don't I don't want to film it with
you bro okay so if we're gonna go
upstairs I'll go off we'll go upstairs
but I don't want this dude up there okay
Sparkles John sold the spotlight that
jabri was attempting to have that day
Tiff Lynn said quote John is clearly the
breakout star this season I could see
that he went from Patrick's brother who
might say or do anything at any moment
to John who might say or do anything at
any moment
there's a difference
speaking of saying or doing anything at
any moment coming in at number two
Jasmine revealing Gino's head to the
world after he showed her nudes to his
ex
what you're gonna do because I'm gonna
sue you what nudes
I'm not gonna lie y'all I slick Miss
Jasmine those weren't nudes
yeah your your breasts are showing
that's correct but they're not nudes
so take off your heart
those are not
iconic those are not Patty said quote so
nobody's gonna ask about that little
pathetic Bush that is on the back of
Gino's head that he really should just
shave
Patty you already know he's insecure
about it let's not make it worse wait
why am I taking up for Gino In This
Moment he deserved all the smoke what he
did was so unacceptable then y'all
remember he went right in his bag and
grabbed another handy dandy hat he had a
backup one prepared Jaylee said quote
Jasmine and Gino earned themselves a
spin-off that scene was so funny good
and sad could you imagine a Jasmine and
Gino spin-off it would be a roller
coaster ride Gino's wild Secrets would
just be coming out randomly
like clockwork but despite his
undercover F boy Tendencies Jasmine
loved him and he loved her and all of
the drama she came with I love him from
ball head to toe just the way he is
weird creepy sometimes I was just very
happy that she gave me a chance
I told y'all before stop laughing at
Gino crying when it comes to Jasmine
Miranda Yanka said quote someone put my
girl on telenova or Broadway immediately
where did you do it
yes she would be great and finally
Andrea Boyer Quest had a really solid
take in my opinion saying Jasmine is one
of the realest most genuine cast members
in franchise history quote she's clearly
been hurt in the past but in my opinion
she's a good person and she clearly
loves with all her heart I hope she
heals and is able to find happiness I
love that Andrea and I totally agree
when I spoke with Jasmine earlier this
year she shared with me that she's
taking steps to become a better woman
I'm doing a lot of meditation you know a
lot of reflection
as a leadership teacher I love writing I
put my emotions into words and paper and
I'm trying to not to judge myself as
hard as I used to do in the past because
then I feel even worse and more guilty
and and that's not you know that's
that's negative as well so I'm trying to
love up and accept myself the way I am
and but uh you know trying just to to
improve all these negative aspects that
I that I know that I have and looking at
them as room for improvement in my
personal romantic any kind of
relationship I might have go Jasmine
when it comes to personal development I
always have to remind myself that it's
not a linear process sometimes you might
feel like you've gone backwards but the
goal is progress and not perfection
all right the top spot on the countdown
of 90 day fiance's biggest must-see
moments in 2022 goes to Kobe breaking
down in tears when meeting his son Cobin
for the first time
it's a welcome
babe are you crying
Kobe look at me oh I need
maybe take a deep breath you're like
hyperventilating
foreign get your tissues ready you see
papa
do you see dada oh my god
get my eye together
[Laughter]
okay
he's looking at you oh my God who is
that you're so cute he looks just like
you
CM said quote seeing a grown man as big
as him cry for his baby boy is the
sweetest thing I mean that moment was
something else it was so sweet I'm
telling you Emily locked up with this
random one night stand she had in China
with Kobe thank God he is as great as he
is because I could have ended up with
someone you know
totally opposite of him and I like do
the today I am mind blown Dana D said
quote Kobe meeting his baby is the most
beautiful moment from all 90 Day Fiance
Seasons I agree if I had to Crown a star
90 Day Fiance cast member for 2022 the
award would go to Kobe
he had his moments like we all do but
overall he just comes off as a
pure-hearted stand-up guy he was really
a breath of fresh air to the 90-day
Universe thank you Kobe alright before I
go I want to shout out the people who
were added to the 90-day MVP list this
year Mike's friend John and nelc also
below's Mom and at this point
I think it's only right to add one more
person guess who
[Music]
yep Kim Son Jamal
for what he's gone through with Kim and
Usman
he deserves it he was definitely the
voice of reason Kim needed and he gave
some Sound Advice hopefully 2023 brings
us more voices of Reason in the 90-day
Universe because Lord knows we need them
all right 90 day fans fam you have been
the absolute best in 2022 you have no
clue how much you've motivated and
inspired me this year your love and
support means so much in 2023 I wish you
a deep sense of happiness that you have
never felt before I'm ready to receive
it may you grow in beautiful ways I wish
you health love and prosperity and every
good thing all right 90 day fans fam
Happy New Year I love you
see you next time
[Music]